this is a production of Cornell
University
so first thank you very much to the
graduate students of plant breeding for
inviting me it's always fun to give a
seminar two colleagues huh here on the
Ithaca campus but it's especially nice
to be invited by graduate students
faculty love that so it is really nice
also I apologize that I missed lunch I
thought lunch was after the seminar
because that's what we do in plant
pathology so I hope you had a great
lunch without me I'm a little bit sad
about that i have to admit so i guess
there's food and michael missouri slab
that i could snag afterwards and today
I'm going to break a bunch of rules that
I give my graduate students when I help
them develop their seminars the first
rule being you should never talk about
want more than one path Oh system it
just gets too confusing and everyone
gets confused but with the title a tale
of two phytophthora you can get the idea
that i am going to be talking about two
paths of systems today and we'll see how
that goes so the symptoms that you see
on the title slide here are symptoms of
the two paths the systems here on the
left hand side is phytophthora blight
caused by phytophthora capsa see and in
the center and on the right hand side
you see phytophthora infestans which
causes late blight of potato and tomato
which is infamous for being the pathogen
involved in the Irish potato famine so
before I really got into the projects I
did want to mention a little bit about
some of the other projects ongoing in my
lab in case any of you folks are
interested I'd be happy to discuss I am
a vegetable pathologist my job is to
study all of those diseases that occur
above ground on vegetables in the state
of New York and there seems to be more
and more every year for a lot of years I
worked on bacterial and all my seat
pathogens and we still have some
bacterial projects we look at work a lot
on cabbage cabbage is a major vegetable
crop going to hit grown here in New York
and then tomato also bacterial spec and
bacterial canker and bacterial canker we
have some interesting projects looking
at the movement of the pathogen
in the plant we do as Lauren said a lot
on pathogen detection and then
population studies today i'll talk about
phytophthora captaincy and infest stands
we do as again Lauren said we also work
on cucurbit downy mildew and then in
recent years I've started some projects
on the true fungi including alternaria
leaf spot on braska crops brown leaf
mold on tomato which hits high tunnel
tomatoes particularly hard and the
newest project in my lab is melampus or
a rust project it's a willow rust on
shrub willow which is now a vegetable in
the state of New York so I also do a lot
of work with growers I spent about half
of my time working with growers and
helping them manage and control their
diseases in both conventional and
organic production I have a very large
out greet outreach program to the
general public including home gardeners
community gardens and K to 12 project
this is our local k to 12 project we
help the elementary school with their
garden and then this semester I'm
teaching a course called skills for
public engagements so on to the
phytophthora on the Left we have
phytophthora blight on the right we have
late blight you might think that there
are very similar diseases they look
pretty similar in culture while they
grow on different media they look fairly
similar the symptoms you see here both
on this tomato leaf and on this pumpkin
are the asexual spores of the pathogen
both pathogens are all my seats they're
not true fungi please don't call them
trufant either in an entirely different
Kingdom and even though they look in
culture like a true fungus they're
really very very different type of
organism I'll bring out some of those
differences as the talk goes on the host
range of the two pathogens is really
quite different and that's the first
area that really separates the two out
here in New York and elsewhere
phytophthora captaincy has a much
broader host range so it attacks all
cucurbits almost all of the solanaceous
crops but not potato snap beans and a
whole diverse array of weeds here are
some of the symptoms are showing fruit
rots here on the bottom of the slide I
should be using this so people in Geneva
can see and on the right-hand side is
the host range of phytophthora infestans
it does have a much more limited host
range the big ones are potato and tomato
it also goes to petunia the nightshade
weeds all these solanaceous guys Nkosi
anna benthamiana is a popular lab rat
for p infest hands work but with even
within the stolen asia it does not
attack pepper or eggplant i think the
fact that infestans doesn't attack
pepper or eggplant and cap to see does
not attack potato is really fascinating
and that's one of the areas that I'd
really like to study over the next 20
years but I'm not right now so when I
was talking some breeders about this and
and someone actually told me I hope it
broke my heart but someone actually told
me please please please don't show us
those darn life cycles we don't care and
I totally care but I don't get the I get
that you guys don't care so I'm just
going to show you the highlights if you
need more come see me so there are some
really important aspects of the life
cycles in New York of both of these
pathogens each pathogen is hetero
phthalic that means you need to mating
types in order to make the sexual
overwintering structures so we cleverly
call the mating types a one and A two
each mating type can make both the male
and female parts but you have to have
both of those mating types in order to
get the overwintering sexual sports with
by top turret capsa see every field we
tested has both mating types we have a
sexually reproducing overwintering
population throughout the state of New
York in phytophthora infestans the late
blight pathogen this is a very clonal
population in the u.s. that is while in
mexico in other parts of the world both
mating types exist and you have sexually
reproduce
in populations here in the US our
populations are clonal in any given year
we'll have one or two or three clonal
lineages that predominate the epidemics
that we see but we don't only rarely see
only rarely do we see sexual
reproduction so we don't have old spores
in the soil so capsa see lifecycle it
over winters in the soil infestans not
so much so asexual reproduction is
really really important phytophthora the
direct translation is plant destroyer
and the reason flight operas are such
excellent plant destroyers is because of
their explosive asexual reproduction
capabilities so these are sporangia
these are what that white fuzz on the
tomato leaf or that powdered sugar
appearance on the fruit those are the
asexual sporangia under the right
conditions each sporangium will produce
those spores that can swim caps to see
when these guys get wet will produce
twenty to forty swimming zoospores
whereas infestans that will be six to
eight those pores are incredibly
interesting structures and I won't bore
you with immense amount of details but
there are a couple of cool things that
you need to know those pores on their ab
axial surface they have two flagella
there by flageolet which makes them
unique among many modal structured modal
spores in nature so thereby flageolet
and the anterior flagellum is actually
two insulated and the posterior is not
the anterior flagellum actually pulls
the zou spore forward rat you know in
most swimming spores you have a
flagellum and it acts like a tail and it
moves along but that is totally not how
these guys work they do the front crawl
and that posterior flagellum actually
acts as a rudder and in some species
their chemotactic so that rudder can
direct them directly to the root zone
where they want to attack and kill the
plant
so all my seats are cool so how do they
spread so if I taught there a cap cecee
being that it's in the soil it spreads
in the soil with movement of soil and
with water oh my seats the common name
would be a water mold and these guys
really do love water capsa see we'll
move wherever water moves it and
wherever someone moves the soil
thankfully there is no aerial dispersal
they cannot move through the air and
that is really one of the Achilles heel
of this pathogen that enables us to
manage it at all in New York CAPTA see
as I said it can move in water whether
it's splash dispersal of water flood
waters and then on soil cultivation
between fields and on movement of
infected fruit which is a very common
way that it gets moved from farm to farm
infestans is all about that aerial
dispersal this is a picture of a tomato
leaf and you see the sporangia on the
bottom there there are these tiny lemon
shaped guys and they actually stick up
off the leaf surface and when the
humidity changes so for example if I had
a detached leaflet in a petri dish high
humidity took that lid off you decrease
the humidity the sporangia actually
twist it's completely awesome they twist
and they d hiss or they break off from
the sporangia for on the leaf and that's
how they become airborne and they can
fly for miles in the wind so the methods
of dispersal of these two pathogens are
very different so the infest dance
because it's a really dispersed and it's
not in the soil then how how does it
survive here in New York well it tends
to survive over winter in potato tubers
so the tooth the pathogen can live
inside that tumor that might be left in
the soil or sitting in a coal pile it
also can get around by movement of
infected plants tubers fruit and sadly
by humans sometimes in trucks as we saw
in
2009 many of your tomatoes may have died
from Lake light that was due to movement
of infected tomato transplants in trucks
so one of the things that I have to do
every year as part of my job is when
there is a total crop failure as is seen
with by Toffler capsa see on this acorn
squash here on the left or with this
potato field and putt phytophthora
infestans on the right I tend to get
called out by the extension educators to
the field talk to the grower try to
figure out what went wrong how we can
fix it in the future that's a really
hard thing to do because I'm standing
there trying to educate but I get paid
whether or not their crop dies and this
person is dealing with a significant
economic loss so one of the things that
I have come to realize is that it's
after these experiences of interacting
with growers after significant crop loss
on that drive home that's when I really
tend to come up with the questions that
my lab is focusing on now so the
questions many of the questions in my
lab are really driven by crop failures
in the field and trying to figure out
what can we do to you now to study and
find out more information to prevent
this into the future so here are some of
the questions that I'm going to cover
today with phytophthora capsa see which
has both sexual and asexual reproduction
in the field questions that growers
always ask you guys will be heartened to
know that no matter the disease growers
almost the first thing they ask is are
there resistant varieties so your work
is being used please continue to breed
resistant varieties then in in terms of
phytophthora a cab to see if I talk
through blight you know what happens
when the pathogen arrives I have it on
my farm you tell me it's mine to keep
it's not going anywhere what do I do now
how long will the pathogen stay in the
soil
really commonly asked question is the
pathogen resistant to the fungicides
that I use and will the pathogen be able
to overcome that host resistance that
you're suggesting that I use with my to
alter and infest dance because the
pathogen really doesn't survive on farm
unless you're keeping tubers that you
shouldn't be keeping the common
questions are what strain of the
pathogen do I have because we have these
asexual clonal lineages people want to
know what strain do I have because we
know based on the clonal lineage is it
does a pervert potato or tomato what
fungicides is it resistant that clonal
lineage gives us some information about
that strain of the pathogen are there
resistant varieties again what about
fungicides where does the pathogen come
from every year that is a question that
advisory panels ask growers panel
growers ask where does this come from
and then again will the pathogen be able
to overcome host resistance and with
phytophthora infestans sadly there is a
very long history of the pathogen
relatively quickly overcoming host
resistance so we'll start with our
sexually reproducing phytophthora capsa
see that causes phytophthora blight stay
with me we're going to have a little
series on phytophthora blight now I
started working on phytophthora blight
in 2006 because there had been several
large outbreaks the pathogen had been in
New York for decades but just a small
problems in the upstate New York with
significant problems down on Long Island
however starting in 2004-2005 there was
some really big epidemics and the reason
for that is because around that time we
started to have a change in our climate
rather than having a quarter inch of
rain a week throughout this summer we
got large reinecke strain events that
that Art Deco tonneau calls extreme
weather events where we would get two or
more inches of rain at a time so with a
water mold you can imagine that if you
get two or more
of rain at a time flooding and puddling
in fields those water moulds go crazy
and once you get an outbreak on one or
two farms then because the pathogen
moves in water and in disease fruit and
on tractor tires it really starts to
spread around so what we have learned
since we started working on it said as I
said earlier we have sexually
reproducing populations in every field
in New York that we've tested the
pathogen is very genetically diverse
which is not surprising given that it's
sexually reproducing there are regional
differences in fungicide sensitivity
which is interesting in the eastern side
of New York we have some fungicide
resistance to a very commonly used honda
side whereas in the western part of New
York we don't we have we did a
significant survey I had a student work
on trying to figure out what what
water's surface waters in New York if I
talked their caps as he could be found
in and we could find it she could find
it almost everywhere irrigation ponds
streams the Erie Canal which people use
for irrigation so any irrigation source
we could find the pathogen present in
floodwaters boy after Hurricane remnants
from Irene and Lee and then superstorm
sandy there were many many farms in
eastern New York that had never had
phytophthora caps to see before that now
have the pathogen we learned something
about resistance working with Michael
Missouri in his lab we know that some
pepper varieties are resistant to New
York isolates were working on getting
more but there is currently no
commercially available resistance in
cucurbits and again along with michael
missouri and my gore were we're working
on that and trying to identify some
resistance in the qubits so that takes
out some of our questions but some of
the questions still remain what happens
when the pathogen arrives into a new
field that had never been infected
before and how long will that pathogen
stay in the soil so one of the really
interesting things about this project is
that the growers in the state of New
York especially upstate were really
wanting someone at Cornell to study if I
talk through capsa see Meg McGrath down
on Long Island had
has done a lot of work but the soils are
different they're the climate is
different there and no one on either the
it occurred Geneva campuses had been
working on this pathogen one of the
reasons is that none of cornell's land
was infested with the pathogen and it I
found out that you know those
horticultural scientists and plant
breeders aren't that enthusiastic about
the plant pathologist inoculating are
Cornell land with a pathogen that has an
extremely broad host range that never
goes away go figure I was shocked so the
growers actually work together with
legislators in Albany and we had a
blight farm built in Geneva New York
about a quarter of a mile from my office
which is totally awesome there was some
there were nine acres of very swampy
land that Cornell was happy to have me
use for a black farm you can see an
aerial photo of it there on the left
this is an outline of the blight farm
here we do a lot of pepper trials you
can see I'll shout out to Missouri lab
these are the controls and these are
some of Missouri peppers there we're
pretty good and we have a barn so
because the pathogen survives in the
soil you don't want to use the equipment
that the plant breeders and the
horticultural scientists might use so we
have equipment a barn anything that we
might need to do trials on our nine acre
farm is part of the farm stays there so
that's where we have been doing research
okay but that soil did not have any of
the pathogen in it either so how do you
inoculate a farm with a pathogen you
know there's not actually that much
scientific literature on that again I
researched but in 2008 we came up with
this idea that thankfully worked we grew
two different strains of the pathogen
the a1 and the a to the two mating types
in big 5 litre flasks that were filled
with vermiculite that had been saturated
with v
eight juice this pathogen loves v8 juice
so we had I think we had 50 flasks of
each isolate growing in sterile
conditions and inoculated them and then
we took those and we mixed them up in
these very scientific plastic garbage
bags and we took that cocktail and
spread it around this beautiful
beautiful pumpkin patch it was an
absolutely gorgeous pumpkin patch on
September 8 and october nine we had
victory so i have to admit that i truly
hate seeing this on a grower farm on our
research farm this is absolute victory
so we were really excited and happy that
we had killed this pumpkin patch all of
the plant breeders and horticultural
scientists were a little bit nervous
when I saw this and they were thankful
that we were on our farm but this was
the start of a by parental population
that we have studied over time this is
Maren Carlson's slide and I use it it's
just absolutely fantastic to demonstrate
what we're looking at in this particular
field so we have our victory field here
on the left that was inoculated with the
a1 and a2 strain so in 2008 it was
inoculated and then in the spring of
2009 is the first time we started to
collect isolates we collect isolates by
planting a susceptible host in the field
they get diseased we bring some of that
diseased tissue in culture the pathogen
and that's how we get the strains the
tricky thing is we really don't know the
generation of the pathogen in the field
because those spores can survive in the
field for a very long time you can have
an f-104 from the first year germinate
and mate with an oz for that was
produced in 2012 so we really don't know
anything about whose mating with whom
after that first inoculation so what are
we doing in our by parental field
population really one of the things we
really wanted
asked was how long will a founding board
survived do we observe generations can
we observe generations over time is
there selfing so the way we did this was
we collected somewhere between 30 and 50
isolates each year from 2009 to 2015 and
in the beginning my graduate student
Amara done used microsatellite analysis
there was a paper from South Africa that
had five microsatellite loci which
remarkably was more than enough for us
to identify variation in the population
she saw variation and genotypes
irregular patterns of inheritance which
is not unusual for the genus
phytophthora and appearance of novel
alleles within three 3 years novel
microsatellite alleles we also did an f1
cross in the lab to use as a control to
know what an f1 population actually
looked like but we knew that we needed
more than five markers so when you need
more markers what do you do you do GBS
that's what we do right so we since that
time Marin Carlson took over the project
and we have a hundred and fifty seven
individuals from the field 43
individuals from our f1 lamb cross and
we've done genotyping by sequencing the
genome of phytophthora capsa see it's
about 64 megabases we used a PE k 1
which seemed to work fine for our
purposes some people that are working
with phytophthora find the APK one
doesn't give them enough cut sites but
it was fine for our purposes Marin was
able to identify about 400,000 snips
before filtering and after her filtering
we're now using about 6,500 so what do
we see again Marin's data we have the a
one-parent in blue up on the top the a
two parent on the bottom this is a
principal components analysis with those
6,500 snips and what you see there's
different colored dots ranging from two
thousand nine to twenty thirteen which
is how far we've gotten to date
and then in magenta are the products of
the lab cross that we know our f1 so
happily we saw sort of what we expected
to see more or less from a popular up by
parental population the progeny are
somewhere in between the two parents
there's a couple of interesting
individuals here these are actually
three individuals from the lab cross
that Mara my previous student had
identified with the five low side to be
self and Marin found the same thing and
then these were two that had not been
previously identified and these are
actually from the field individuals from
the field that are also identified as
selfs that is one parent mating with
itself because in the header phthalic oh
my seat each individual can produce both
the ogo neum the female part and
anthurium the male part they can self
and so that's that's how we got those
individuals out there kind of
interesting Marin has done some really
interesting work on those ah but for the
purposes of this seminar what we were
really looking for was how long did
those original founding old spores stay
in the field so what we have in this
violin plot is our F ones on the right
hand side we know that they're f1's the
first time we were able to collect
isolates with 2009 and so in 2009 and
2010 the hetero zygosity which is what
you're looking at here was very similar
to what we saw with f1's starting in
2011 this is really great what we see is
that there are some individuals that
have a level of heterozygosity similar
to that of the f1's but then we're
starting to see some individuals that
have less heterozygosity which would be
an indicator of inbreeding what we also
see is as we move into 2012 and 2013 as
again a reduction in heterozygosity so
we're looking at inbreeding and now
while this isn't really surprising this
is actually the first time that we've
been able to show this for a field
population of phytophthora capsa see so
it's really kind of exciting it'll be
really fun to see what happens in the
next several years if we continue to see
a reduction in heterozygosity or if it
levels off because we are selecting for
those individuals that can kill a plant
right we only can collect isolates on a
plant that is dying from symptoms so
because we're selecting we're probably
losing individuals that are no longer
pathogenic so it'll be interesting to
see what happens in this field so what
have we learned from our GBS with the by
parental population we have found that
the founding Oh spores stay for about
three years based on Marin's work there
are there are individuals that appear to
be f1's for about three years and the
inbred o spores are there for longer and
then how so that's what happens when it
arrives and that's also how long we
think the pathogen will stay in the soil
now again because of selection we we
don't know that this is exactly what
would happen in a growers field but we
do hope to compare these data to what we
see in a growers field as time goes on
so what's next in with the phytophthora
cap to see which has the sexual
reproduction well we need additional
studies on the genetics actually Marin
is doing a lot of really fascinating
additional studies on the genetics of
this by parental population as i said
earlier phytophthora cap CC is known to
have interesting genetics so she's
actually able to use this population to
learn more about loss of heterozygosity
gene conversion and it's it's really
been fun to learn more about the
pathogen in this field setting as i said
we also want to compare our research
field to grower fields sadly there are
more than enough grower fields for us to
compare to and then Marin is actually
doing an association study to look for a
region associated with mating type but
there are other phenotypes
that we will certainly want to look for
in the future such as fungicide
resistance or effectors that enable the
pathogen to more effectively attack the
host so we are now going to switch gears
and talk about a sexual reproduction for
a little while so this is a whole new
system similar yet completely different
so we're switching to pee and fest hands
it's a really dispersed but there's and
people have been studying phytophthora
infestans for a hundred and sixty-five
years but it's still one of the most
feared pathogens of tomato and potato
growers across the world it's it's a
frustrating system to work with research
our researchers are frustrated and
growers are frustrated so one of the
biggest questions that the first
question a grower ass is what strain do
I have as I said earlier because these
are asexual a sexually propagated you
have these clonal lineages and people
want to know what strain do I have
because that will help them know what
fungicides to use what host to plant
things like that are there resistant
varieties is the pathogen resistant to
commonly used fungicides and this is a
very interesting question where does the
pathogen come from every year if it's
not coming from our soil and then
finally will the pathogen be able to
overcome the host resistance so these
are data from bill fries lab and he as
many of you know is probably the world
expert in research on phytophthora
infestans and one of the things that
builds lab has studied for a very long
time are these clonal lineages he's a
sexually reproducing populations and
what this slide shows is his ability to
identify quickly clonally ages and the
change in clonally inches lineages over
time so for example in the potato graph
we have from 2009 to 2014 as we do in
the tomato graph each color is a
different asexually reproducing
population or clonal lineage so the
bottom line from this slide
that yes clonally just change over time
and yes we can fairly rapidly identify
them starting in 2011 we really had a
boost in our ability to understand
what's going on with my toddler infest
hands because a large group of us about
28 labs across the country were involved
in a USDA cap grant and bill fries
portion of that one of his projects as
part of that was that people from around
the country sent phytophthora infestans
isolates to his lab and he Gina typed
them using microsatellite Eugenia typed
them within 24 hours and got that
information back to them now this was
great for people because they would know
what clonal age they were working with
but it was also great for us because
suddenly we had this huge collection of
isolates with which we could work as
part of the project several labs around
the country also took that isolate
collection and tested them for
sensitivity to commonly use fungicides
so the resistant varieties there there
are resistant varieties which the
pathogen frequently can overcome
actually breeders are working especially
in tomato on increasing the number of
resistant varieties there's some really
nice our genes in tomato that are being
bred into lots of different commercially
available varieties now which is great
but the question that remained that we
wanted to look at was where does the
pathogen arrive from every year so zac
hanson one of my graduate students has
been working on this project and again
we we wanted to use some method to
understand if we could identify
individuals within that asexual clonal
lineage so these would be mutations that
occurred over time through mitosis right
completely a sexually and we wanted to
know if we could identify variation and
if so could we identify sub lineages or
variants that we could track across the
country
and the reason we wanted to do this is
that we hope that it will better enable
us to understand how epidemics start
right so do they start from some source
of inoculum that's a potato tuber in a
home grower home gardeners you know
backyard or are they starting from
transplants that get moved by truck or
potato to receive that gets moved around
the country again this was part of our
cap grand it was a huge community effort
we looked at we Zach looked at 257
isolates from four different clonal
lineages clonal lineages are named they
started with us one they're named by the
country that you first identify them in
and then chronologically as newly ages
come along so us eight is the oldest
lineage that we looked at it first
appeared in the 1990s and we looked at
also us 11 us 23 and US 24 most of the
isolates were from between 2011 and 2014
because that was the time period of the
grant that we were working on those were
submitted to bills labview genotype them
save them away and those are the
isolates that we use for this particular
study so Zach was able to use apk1 again
identify snips within lineages and the
first thing we wanted to do was look at
the genetic differences within a lineage
so our hypothesis would be that the
oldest lineage us8 would have the most
diversity of isolates was in that
lineage because it's been around the
longest and when Zach went through the
culture collection we were able to get
by far the largest number of isolates
from the clonal lineage us 23 the reason
for that is for the last three years
that's almost the only lineage that
we've seen in North America so anybody
who sent in an isolate it's going to be
us 23 and he had between 20 and 30 of
the other three lineages you can also
see here after filtering the number of
snips that
were identified and used in these
analyses and the oldest lineage did have
the highest level of diversity but even
that was really not it there's not a
huge amount of diversity as one might
expect within a clonal age but we did
identify some diversity he did do an
experiment where he used the exact same
isolate and performed GBS seven
different times and so that was sort of
our background control and this point 0
for 3 was the level of diversity sort of
within our control group so that was
sort of our background if it's not
higher than that now we know it it's not
worth looking at so Zach also did a
principal components analysis and on the
entire group of 257 isolates and
thankfully and happily where he was able
to differentiate the four clonal
lineages that were working with it was
known prior to this study that the two
lineages us eight and US 24 were fairly
closely related so we knew that the
system was working at least at some
level um what I'm going to show today is
actually only the data from the US 23
clonal lineages because we had 166
isolates and and this really gave us the
most interesting story with only 20 to
30 isolates we really did not have
enough data to to try to look at
regional differences compared to annual
differences but with the US 23 isolates
in this particular neighbor-joining tree
that they're categorized by collection
year and you can't really see very many
yellow 2009 was the first year that the
Kelowna lineage in u.s. 23 was
identified we only had two isolates from
that inaugural year three isolates from
2010 you can see here that two of the
three isolates from 2010 clustered
together but then again because of this
grant and people sending isolates in in
2011 2012 2013 and 2014 we had many more
I slit so interestingly in 2011 and 2012
the isolates are fairly evenly dispersed
across the neighbor-joining tree or up
and down the neighbor-joining tree but
in 2013 and 2014 we could actually see
some grouping by year so these green
isolates here in Group A are 11 isolates
all collected in 2014 and they were
collected from these states Florida
Massachusetts New York North Carolina
and Idaho so well if I taught there
infestans can fly a long way it's pretty
unlikely that it was it would have the
ability to fly from Florida to Idaho in
the average season of the potato or
tomato crop so that was pretty
interesting to us in Group B we had 14
isolates collected from 2013 again with
a fairly wide ranging group of states oh
when we tried to categorize these by
state or region we didn't come up with
any groupings but when we did these
categories by year we came up with
several groupings even in just 166
isolates one of the problems with this
study is that we don't have the same
number of isolates from any every year
for sure so yes we need more data but I
was really excited about these initial
data that we got so as I said we did not
see any evidence for Geographic sub
lineages so if all of our inoculum was
coming from infected tubers or there's
been a report that tomato fruit the
season tomato fruit can-can house
phytophthora infestans overwinter in
wisconsin so if all of our inoculum were
coming from local sources we would
expect to see regional the geographic
sub lineages right if all of our
inoculum if inoculum were not coming
from local sources but were was rather
being moved around
on seedlings or tubers or people then
you might expect to see clustering by
year and that's what what we see so
based on these data my current
hypothesis is that at least in some of
those cases the pathogen is moving long
distances in a short period of time
probably in a truck and and this is what
everyone has assumed that you know the
pathogen can move around but it's really
interesting to have some data to start
to look at that and certainly you know
some of these individual lines here when
we get more data we might see both
regional you know sub lineages as well
as annual sub lineages because the most
likely scenario is that both regional
sources and trucked sources are moving
an ocular mehran the country so in the
last so the last question this is
perfect the last two minutes the area
that we're going to be looking at next
is will the pathogen be able to overcome
host resistance and when anyone asks
this a plant pathologist is always going
to say of course the pathogen will be
able to overcome host resistance history
a hundred and sixty-five years of
history tells us that certainly the
pathogen will overcome host resistance
but can we get some data to back that up
so one of the areas of plant pathology
that I have been watching from the
sideline is a really fascinating area of
studies on effectors it actually has its
own little term called effector omics
effectors are proteins that are secreted
by plant pathogens to help them infect
the plant and one of the interesting
things about effectors is that our
proteins from plants will recognize the
effector and that's how the our protein
works so if we can get a better idea of
what effectors are present in a pathogen
population and you guys have enough
diversity in our genes then we might be
able to say hey
this field has this set of effectors
moszer 'ok what plant do we want to put
there that would be awesome that's like
precision agriculture at the pathology
breeding level and and I absolutely
believe that this will be possible
within the next 20 years the reason I
believe that is because of my friends
Paul Burch and Ingo Hine at the James
Hutton Institute and they came up with
this technology that they called in
effector enrichment and sequencing and I
personally did not come up with it with
their name but it's called F and seek
and Paul said you always know if the
audience is listening when you say F and
seek so f and seek what they have done
is they have made a biotinylated RNA
bait for a huge number of effectors from
both phytophthora infestans and
phytophthora capsa see they have from
phytophthora capsa see all my seats the
most famous type of effector is an
effector that has a protein motif amino
acid motif called our XLR so they have
509 our XLR effectors in cap cecee and
then in cab chassis there's also an
interesting group of effectors called
crinkle errs because when they
infiltrated them into the new coach
hanumanth ami onek crinkled the leaf
anyway so they have 65 crinkle Erick
vectors and then in infest as you can
see they have a lot of effector baits
for infestans as well so they have these
RNA baits that are ready to go that have
been biotinylated and the way it works
is you take your genomic DNA from each
of the isolates of interest you cut it
at a adapter so that you'll be able to
amplify it in the end take your RNA bait
hybridize them together as i said the
RNA bait is coated in biotin then you
take your streptavidin coated magnetic
beads put them together the stripped
avidin binds to the blood
cartoon you add a magnet because the
magnetic beads will then come to the
magnet you have your little pool of
effectors you then degrade the RNA away
and you have after amplifying the entire
effector set of every isolate that you
can then sequence so they've done this
on a small number of isolates and it's
been effective they've done it on
isolates that have genome sequences so
they know the effect your compliment
that's there what these guys don't have
is a huge collection of isolates that
you could then identify the effectors
and go back and test them on host plants
to see if that pathogen was then
susceptible or resistant on that host
plants so validation so that is our next
step for both the fight opera capsis II
and the phytophthora infestans we plan
to perform f and seek with the folks at
James Hutton again as I said this will
give us some functional testing of the
alleles and allelic variants that they
have identified to see if an allelic
variant will actually enable an able to
the path of the pathogen to get around
the resistance of the plant the goal
would then have this lead to a
diagnostic where in fact you could go
into a field fairly rapidly get 50
isolates determine what effectors they
have and then figure out what would be
the best plant to put in that field for
caps to see that would work because you
have relatively few new individuals
coming into a field for infestans what
would be really interesting is to
understand the variability of effectors
within those asexual clonal lineages you
know so bill fries lab has some evidence
that there is some variability
especially in the older lineages but it
would be really fascinating to know what
kind of variability there is that would
help us manage the pathogen and also it
would be interesting to see if the
effect of variability correspondent in
any way to the variability within
lineage that we saw with the GBS so even
though I hope you agree
even though to fight after species are
very different my lab has been able to
use similar strategies to understand the
pathogen populations and by
understanding these populations we
firmly believe that we will be able to
improve disease management strategies
acknowledgments this is my lab here on
the right the phytophthora captaincy
work was done by a previous student
Amara done along with maren carlson the
infestans work done by zac hanson and
maren did a lot of the bioinformatics a
whole list of collaborators we've been
funded by for the captcha see through
the state of New York Department of Ag
and markets along with several different
grant panels from nifA a long list of
collaborators that are also very
important and with that I will answer
any questions ah yes yeah so the
question is is there a possibility of
hybridization between cap CC and
infestans and in some phytophthora
species you can hybridize but not these
two so the question is do we know which
are genes map with which our match with
which effectors and in some cases yes
and in some cases no for for the
defeated our genes we tend we tend to
know what they are for some actually in
the for the our gene that's most common
in pepper we do not know the effector
yet but there are a lot of folks working
on that so I feel like by the time we
were to a point where we could actually
do some field base diagnostic that
information be available I should ask
for questions from geneva alright so
Larry's Larry's question is what's
driving that change in population
structure in infest and so there's
really one dominant clonal lineage and
and the answer is that no one knows for
sure but my hypothesis is that that
particular clonal lineage is
it is being dispersed widely it was
widely found in several regions that are
both tomato transplant production and
potato seed production and so so I think
it's just at the moment the lineage
that's being most widely dispersed what
we've seen history would tell us that in
the next two or three years will have a
new clonal lineage that arrives probably
from Mexico that is bigger and beefier
and has less genetic bottlenecks and
that will start to take over the over
the world but it would be fantastic if
that one same clonal lineage date around
a bit longer because we actually know
how to control it why do you think you
think it would come up Mexico alright so
why would I come up from Mexico so
Mexico is the center of origin of
phytophthora infestans and it has a
sexually reproducing population and we
have a fairly significant trade with the
country of Mexico so the most likely
source of entry would be Mexico just
because that's where the largest amount
of diversity is in other parts of the
world the pathogen is predominantly
clonal so if we get a new lineage from
somewhere else in the world we would
immediately know that because those
lineages are already known back oh right
so Nancy's question is the founding Oh
spores lasts about three years based on
the day that we've seen that in Britain
bread Oh sports last longer we don't
actually know that what we'll find that
out what we know right now is that that
they're there my guess just I guess
because what I've seen in growers fields
the pathogen remains for a fairly long
time so that's probably why I said early
chances are they last longer but and and
over time you'll get new new inbreds
right I guess my thinking would be that
any o spore will live for three years
but after you lose the founders like in
Marin's little diagram yeah the guys
over here are always going to be in
bretts what we don't know is if we're
going to see a reduction in
pathogenicity due to inbreeding and we
it's hard to tell that in a grower field
because you never know if new inoculum
has
men but we should be able to see that in
our field right so how much genetic
variation is there within a clonal
lineage or among but between between the
kelowna lineages right so within lineage
variation is more rare between them
between lineage variation and the
numbers for between lineage variation
with our GPS data are known but I don't
have them off the top of my head but
there's much more variation between the
lineages that within the lineage so it
is true that this is the first time that
we've really been able to look at
variation within a clonal lineage with
microsatellites lineage you know all of
the 166 isolates were not identical but
about a hundred and fifty of them had
the exact same SSR genotype with 12
microsatellite loci there were some
variants and so a very individual I
think there may be 10 to 15 variance
would have a new allele at one of the
twelve low sigh interestingly when we
looked at those variants in the location
in the neighbor-joining tree the GPS
data was unrelated to whether or not
there was SSR variant that's what we
know
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu